je disais et vous lisiez également cette
autre manifestation aujourd'hui sur
appel du leader des patriotes florian
philippot c'est dans le 16e
arrondissement bonjour sirène ici c'est
surtout le passé vaccinale qu'on est non
c'est bien ça
absolument admirable si c'est le pass
vaccinale que l'on dénonçons le
dénoncent eux toujours dans la bonne
humeur comme depuis 16 mois cela fait
maintenant 16 mois que la maître laminé
les manifestations ici se déroule pour
actuellement l'ambiance est au beau fixe
sur la place de barcelone le point de
ralliement habituel et vous pouvez le
voir sur ces images de ces liens maginel
ils sont quelques dizaines pour le
moment à être sous le soleil parisien
venu dénoncer le pas ce qu'ils appellent
le pass de la honte se passe sanitaire
qui était devenu passe vaccinale le 24
janvier dernier c'est une initiative de
florian philippot le chef de parti des
patriotes qui a justement annoncé hier
soir qu'il ne serait plus candidat à la
présidentielle faute de parrainages mais
l'ancien bras droit de marine le pen a
dit ne rien lâcher côté manifestants les
annonces de gabriélat tel concernant la
fin d'un pass vaccinale aux alentours
fin mars début avril n'est pas
convaincante c'est une annonce qu'il
pense être une stratégie électorale je
vous propose de les écouter
je pense que le combat afin de continuer
jusqu'au bout je suis je suis persuadé
qu on nous manipule encore on nous dit
qu'on suspend le pass vaccinale et non
le on le supprime pas donc c'est un
problème en fait parce que nous ce qu'on
demande c'est la suppression et non la
suspension
olivier ferrand a dit qu'il allait le
remettre cet hiver donc je trouve ça un
peu bizarre
comment peut-il être devin et savoir qu
on aura encore besoin l'hiver prochain
dans quel but est ce parce vaccinale on
ne comprend toujours pas se passer c'est
une absurdité c'est une absurdité totale
c'est alger sous la barre des 76 ans je
devrais être mort si on écoutait vers
hanche devrait être moins déjà depuis
longtemps à 76 ans je suis pas mort je
n'ai jamais été vaccinés contre la
grippe bon ceux qui veulent se faire
vacciner ya pas de soucis sont vaccinés
mais après c'est la liberté de chacun la
liberté elle est toujours pas là et je
suis pas certain qu'on va la gagner avec
les présidentielle qui approche vu les
vieux les façons de faire pour les
parrainages par exemple on voit bien que
c'est il ya quelque chose qui va pas
bien derrière tout cela il ya une
pression et les maires ne veulent pas
signer par exemple pour florian on
s'aperçut qu'il avait qu'une seule voie
de de vraiment à l'idée alors qu'il
avait 384
voix au départ donc de promesses et
finalement elles n'ont pas abouti
et le cortège devrait s'élancer d'ici
quelques minutes en direction de la
place pierre laroque dans le 7e
arrondissement non loin du ministère de
la santé le temps de finir de mettre en
place le système sont d'attendre les
derniers arrivants et d'honnête
l'encadrement sécuritaire nécessaire
afin d'éviter tout débordement
merci un sérielle pour toutes ces
précisions